welcome everybody to my dumb friends we
are this is the first episode we've ever
had without one of our co-hosts which is
Sean Donnelly and I'm really excited
about this because if this goes well
that means that saint-germain podcast
which I really think that the comedy
world has been seeking so today
replacing Sean is Andy Haines my good
buddy
you've seen him on his own Comedy
Central half-hour special Jimmy Fallon
Conan and more importantly he goes to
the same gay a a men's meeting that you
were your handlebar moustache David
remember like you had a wife and I was
thinking that's a great night I get so
much [ __ ] me and Andy are trying to uh
who can [ __ ] the girl who just got off
the bus from Kansas yeah the Greyhound
station I'm a USC it just doesn't care
anymore
oh dude don't raise your [ __ ] 9 a.m.
thank you for doing this what is this
this is the only time we had I'm gonna
say I'm free tomorrow I'm starting a new
wife well yeah are you going up there
where are you going
doing docks tomorrow night and then I'm
doing some indie shows I mean few nights
from now I'll tweet them for you I'm
from there East Bay now Barrow San
Francisco we're puttin well a Richmond
District for forever 10th Avenue then I
lived in Lone Mountain you know that
moon mountain Lone Mountain that's right
by the college USC I mean USC yeah yeah
one with the tower like you started out
from a gas station teacher like you just
like in Roger Rabbit this is my look
this year I've haven't got a hundred
bucks if you google me what's the worst
look you think I've ever had like what
just like what look do you walk back on
now and you're like you know I don't
have any I'm not embarrassed and Jake
owes things no no
but you were like on the Sunset Strip
and like yeah but I don't I don't mind
that look max I'd actually rocked that
look right now if I had like better hair
you know tight pants right now no but
did you have like the leather pants I
wore leather pants for about 10 years
straight scarf scarf are the difference
between rock and roll images I was
always into like like Jim Morrison meets
like biker meets you know like G&R
Street look I like that or even dirty
Jane's Addiction and even dirtier like
Seattle Jane's Addiction was great funny
you you you sang him play guitar right
yeah that's right I said was a lead
singer for like 20 years and then I
finally learned guitar okay I was
reading on your website last night who
are you open well I'm open for a lot of
got wallflowers for 10 months I went
around the world with him that was Jakob
Dylan a nice guy he's my best friend
yeah I would be the best comedian and
that is a [ __ ] I mean like obviously
this has been said of a time before but
talk about like a weight to bear being
Bob Dylan yeah yeah and then and then
pulling through pulling through yeah I
mean like it's just a bit songs I mean
we all know those star kids we're
talking about Dylan who's the highest
right now you know there's no higher
than that in the music so I've seen way
WAY lower star kids that are just
gardening I'm friends with Frankie Muniz
his cousin so I know exactly yeah how
that goes Jacob is a amazing friend he's
a good dude what's the worst show you've
ever done cuz I always what's the
difference okay what does never see the
like what's worse the worst comedy shave
ever doing the worst run is really
really yeah
what was this well cuz you got a sound
check bring gear
there's also it's like like you're
setting only failure yeah so you set it
all up you got your [ __ ] van your
sound check and then you go eat dinner
or whatever and you come back and
there's no one there
hey you're hoping the other ghosts yeah
let's just pay and get you out of here
nope they want you to play to the four
people
and so you're up there for the 90-minute
set and just going [ __ ] but I don't go
ahead comedy for people I can do
something with some work I can do some
new [ __ ] and just be like and sometimes
a four-person crowd you like
well that wasn't that bad yeah yeah a
four-person music crowd is just a bummer
it's loud it's just a studio session
yeah exactly
people brought their friends yeah I
forgot who was talking about it but
there was a there was a show that's a
friend did nobody showed up like
literally zero people and the Booker was
like I paid you for the time and say
made him perform to know that Barry
Rothbart I think he did a college one
that was like that it could have been
where he had to do like a 45-minute set
to an empty room in a comedy show last
year was some big theater in Anaheim the
guys like oh yeah it held like 750 so
like 50 people showed up for don't even
see them held the show he held the show
for people in a theatre he sat in the
back
oh so it's two people really what a
[ __ ] night in New York and I New York
I would end up saying no this like Andy
doesn't plenty does reduce show no one
shows up and it's just you in the comics
and then the guy who runs it goes you
know what let's do it for each oh I
finally like know like if the person was
doing it less time than me or like
hasn't you know I get has no experience
I make no we're not we're all gonna go
home I just had to but I said to Booker
is getting a fight one time over that
where one was like let's be nice and
cancel and the other one was well the
reason that they don't want it it's even
more twisted is that like then they know
that they can't get booked on whoever
they books show yeah the Briggs J
our exchange rate yeah yeah yeah you
know is that one of those shows and
you're like oh yeah I see what's going
on here yeah hey I'll put you three on
my show you put me on your show just
Booker exchange do you have a girlfriend
now or no no no I just I just know I
just do comedy that's it I'm afraid to
get a chick completely because the last
thing you've been in that's what like
last thing that you were in relationship
yeah I never had a bed before this the
new gender neutrality what's the last
thing you were what's the last uh none
oppressive thing you know what am was I
had one great relationship for like
seven years raise the bar and it's just
[ __ ] me for life yeah I had a great
one and then I just traded it for rock
and roll and what was this who was the
great one well I had this girl for like
seven years you weren't doing music at
all no I was like 20s and then I just
kind of was like well I got to play rock
and I mean it's married now no she's not
which is crazy but it was prior I come
to her house with Randy Newman playing
in the [ __ ] car no but I do like
texture once so I like let's try it
again and she's like no yeah they're
when they're done they're done she's
gonna see that change your mind once you
[ __ ] a comic for enough years it's that
never becomes attractive again well I
guess you were music yeah yeah I've
almost every girl that I've seriously
dated I'm like don't [ __ ] oh my good to
me and they're like why would I ever
[ __ ] comic is literally the least
attractive option the only people that
are that stupid or female comics sorry I
know I'm gonna get skewered for that
we're not giving any names I don't [ __ ]
any comedians or people around the club
there's like you know people if you
think of girls not funny now I just I
don't
thank you I don't want to [ __ ] anyone in
the biz yeah it's gonna you're you work
every night you're like there they are
there they are I've actually made that
mistake yeah and I taking that all back
I think women are hilarious but for some
reason people keep on [ __ ] each other
yeah and then it's the most awkward
hallway at the Comedy Store
yeah that's insane I don't want to get
into that because that's like Mike my
tree fort I love that place I would hate
to have it to be like oh no yeah that
yeah or the one where you go on stage
and go oh she's here gotta go and you
just leave the place you love but here's
my here's my role like I would never
call girl a [ __ ] yeah you know what I
mean so I can't get it like I just I
mean you've done that ever they were
you've like been in serious
relationships with comedians so I've
never I was married to one yeah you were
married to one side was it alice
wetterlund I don't know her she's more
another one though right
I dated a younger yeah a girl ester
Steinberg I also dated that's right I
don't know lilia Phillips it was emo
Phillips's is that true no but yes so
you yeah you seriously didn't like three
comedians well yeah I would like a
comedian that had their career going and
stuff yeah but when we're both like well
Paula Poundstone is here right we have a
weird dating game with her what do you
guys feel about shoulder-pads
MADtv get ready did she have like nine
cats here's my chasm that she got I
think some child abuse occasions she got
adopted what about Tom what's it Tommy
observers would adopt it a whole bunch
of kids and then then there was
allegations of her sexually abusing them
and they took all the kids well this is
the first time we've heard from Tom a
deposition in like a molestation case
was about a Sandusky's Miracle Mile Tom
what was experienced on there okay but
Dean did did you ever go I think she got
the kids back right she got him back
they were false
yeah they yeah they she no she pleaded
like some kind of no contest thing so
there was something there that she did
and then they let her have like
supervised access for like a number of
years and she made all sleeping Blazers
hello what if Tom just endured like what
have you interrupted with those facts in
every podcast
Marin's jog on Obama so tell us about
one second I'm so glad I didn't come up
in the Blazer comedy era you know I
don't think I would I think I'd like to
do blazer but no shirt underneath yeah
[ __ ] move this diamond Dave stopped I
used to see Paula at the other cafe in
San Francisco
Oh like way back in place yeah that was
an amazing place and and then how how
did she do she was great yeah wasn't she
well that era that era was here G had
Alex Bennett Paula Poundstone Carrie
snow they had that morning radio show
wait on the quake on the quake and it
was [ __ ] massive and comedy in San
Francisco was bigger than anywhere yeah
I heard they used to they used to show
the San Francisco Comedy Competition
show on TV it was so big when you won
that it was like like you know being on
Ellen Ellen who but it was a world
stand-up was great it was unlike HBO it
was like amazing I'm not a special in
about two thousand two or three on HBO
good it was awesome man yeah it was
great yeah she's one of those people I
kind of wish you'd stayed in it yeah me
too she still does it she does like a
special every three years or something
right but I think you know it's like
it's it's those highly produced I don't
think she's workshop
but I'm not like you know like Izzard
will still go out and do like small
theatres in like hundred thousand person
towns yeah you like actually touch the
ground yeah but I think she just hits
like Wembley Stadium does an hour was
back to her she does it in the same
place that Steve Jobs unveiled you guys
see that show I think it was probably in
the mid 90s worse it was the city zoo
show yeah it was Patton and blaine
capatch yeah sure I think that's what it
looked like a New York subway tile
behind I remember just like a great and
I think I want to say like Dana Gould
was in the bay and yeah yeah and Rhodes
is in the bay I don't know everybody but
it was like a really strong scene at the
time yeah I had seen Marilyn Rice my
podcast she was talking about you know
everybody would do brainwash which is
that laundry mat and they have an open
mic at night and yeah that's so good
it'll go still [ __ ] go that guy yeah
what's the guy that's the host I don't
know but it's great all the greats were
in there you know I would do stuff in
there back in I my when I was first in
the Bay Area the guy that really knocked
me out was Bobcat yeah he's the best
yeah I mean he came to town and
everybody thought I thought that was a
real like homeless guy everybody thought
this homeless guy and I and I went I
would see him all the time and I
recently met him through Marin you know
and I had a ticket stub and I was like
look man I saw you at Wolfgang's 850 and
he's like kidding buy a beer there for
that now but he was incredible and Robin
Williams you know and all that scene I
opened for Bob ken Virginia and it was
such a you know I grew up like when I
was like six is when Police Academy came
out sound like that and I hugged him and
he was not ready for that hug I was like
doing this okay and then walked back
this is what how old were you then the
hug or the kid hug hug two years three
years ago an eg you were just going
through the divorce though right two or
three years ago help
I imagine you like tears are coming down
here I get it's not about the hug it's
about everything else that's going on
here but the first time Bobcat actually
breaks into the Bobcat voice like yeah
he's really good I just saw his
documentary about Barry Crimmins oh he's
a sweet guy the Bigfoot movie saw that
yeah yeah director yeah yeah he goes
kind of all over the place yeah the
other one what was that one about where
they go around shoot people that are
rude in America god Bless America I can
funny a [ __ ] and didn't he do like a he
did he's done a bunch of TV like he was
Meryl Kim all he drinks marinade or
experience yeah but yeah that's how I'm
pretty little liars at no it doesn't but
I want to start that rumor and when
those guys went a bobcat and Tom Kenny
hit San Francisco that was like a new
like younger guys coming in like post
bobby slate and ran all that that era
you know that was a does a blast and
those guys are best friend but Tom Kenny
and Bobcat Goldthwait bet best friends
from Rochester New York
I was worried I was time you're like the
Matt Pinfield of music yes thank you I
met the Matt Pinfield about three months
ago it was so weird because I had shared
buying heroin office I had that Jesse
camp on my podcast I'm like oh somebody
somebody but rolled him reasons like Joe
Mande or somebody trolled him on Oh what
did you mean say they just were like hi
Jesse on Twitter and they did it for
like a week and he just eventually like
blew up and blocked them yeah I had him
on two episodes he was the worst is he
still the Tweaker I know you know turns
out he's he's got a little bit of paper
man he
yeah Jesse yeah he's got some money
honey make some money well you know
remember they busted him his his parents
were rich back on the day and Spin
Magazine did that like research on him
and he was supposed to be kind of like
this you know you know rock child of the
streets and stuff but he was really like
from Connecticut and went to like a
great school but you know what I had him
on a couple episodes and it was
fantastic man he he he knows what it is
does he have a gimmick anymore
does he like stops that he's like not at
all like that and then he gets into kind
of reality he got busted dealing speed
and a Hollywood Boulevard and Sharon you
have any left level that's how he goes
to his gay I want the one thing that
everybody forgets about Bobcat I think
he talks about in his act he was
descended from the ceiling of was it the
MOR somewhere as butt-naked with angel
wings for a Nirvana concert yeah that's
very normal like it started about I wake
just mention it because I feel like that
guy gets that question boot and I was
like how was you know kersek nicest you
know I I think he was like more of a
nice guy than like yeah everybody you
know that whole like that was almost
like [ __ ] like a person like keep
people away sort of thing yeah when I
was like 12 I was like sneaking into all
the grunge music concerts and that's the
one band I didn't see was Nirvana the
best one yeah I stopped Pearl Jam and
Soundgarden rolls great I liked Alice in
Chains
Soundgarden was my favorite that loud
love record man it was like the new
Sabbath
you know [ __ ] that records crap man it's
like sad I was more of a Maisie
playground guys oh yeah it's more of a
Macy Gray guy
she wasn't [ __ ] bad man she had some
good - these are real cuca now that's a
great sound like the muppet the teach
you about that teaches you about
littering the c1y the boulder theater
like two nights after married and I come
where people why the [ __ ] is her name
bigger than wow that's big [ __ ]
theater man I don't know well yeah I
feel like yeah that's so funny is it so
you like if you're doing well as a
comedian you start to play people like
musicians you knew ten years ago yeah
and if you're going if you're doing
badly as a musician you're starting to
play theatres the comedian's rook
assaults playing they're like what the
[ __ ] is premium boy there was that like
Fiona Apple she's great I have like chew
her up she is great but I'm saying that
so ha ninety hot Isaac you know macy
gray
she's buddies with Galifianakis I heard
do they date I think they maybe did but
they definitely don't know she's single
she into guys who has a baby oh come on
Jack Jack - what do you feel better
latter less talented
Bob Seger gal phonetic how low is your
bar Fiona
that's my question she's gotta have
crazy paper those records soldiers and
she'd I don't think she has to because
she doesn't really do she doesn't work
much now
she had album like what four years ago
Paul Thomas Anderson right opt a man
yeah and is that whose her baby daddy um
no I actually think it's God I was
thinking trying to think of a funny
reference to Trent Reznor early I'll try
to think of it like a director guy who's
like notoriously a terrible to scott
redneck scott right she was a brett
ratner found out [ __ ] fiona apple was
dating brett ratner i jump in front of a
[ __ ] train Metrolink but you can
handle your [ __ ]
can we talk about that Andy with you
yeah of course I talk about in my act
yeah I get to get people from the
program getting mad at me and reminded
me of you're like oh I always get the
two like okay well you gotta think is
that gonna deter people from go like
nobody's [ __ ] looking at me and being
like oh man we'll get Dan I really need
to get sober yeah yeah I mean like I
hate that what is it the first up it's
cool now if you go to rehab okay [ __ ]
a an eating disorders not cool sex
addiction is not cool there's certain
things yeah that aren't cool still but
like [ __ ] having a booze or drug
problem and get it's like cool mail
everybody does well that's just standard
yeah an industry hey in LA is crazy
there's some like 5,000 meetings a week
or something yeah is it more than New
York
yeah for sure it's the most prolific
it's also networking yeah and check the
casting director for bones
people just shout out who's at their
meetings it's supposed to be all private
they're like Aziz here yeah so you you
had like a so you can kind of handle
your chefs have you have you have like
what's the what's the most manager
you've gotta have had I just I have a
feeling that you had that you've had one
of those moments where you're like my
heart stopping Oh
left arm numb yeah arm heroin no from
coke just left arm numb wow I was doing
coke
one night in this Hollywood Hills
mansion the one where Chili Peppers did
that big wrecker was Ruben before Ruby I
feel like this should just be like a
spotlight on you and one microphone and
like a cigarette in your hand get me on
storytellers I got crazy I just say that
about whatever show anyone has get me up
48 hours please give me on that moth mic
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah so there was like it was the first
time this is 80s where after Scarface
people would always say there's pyramid
of coke at the party which I was always
[ __ ] you know through--the this
particular party there was an actual
pyramid of coke like you saw at the end
of Scarface and it was just on a table
and you could just help yourself and I
was like oh yeah and I went up you can
just help yourself oh yeah
when was this this is like 89 so that I
was just like are you on coke no ma'am
what are you talking about everyone just
go in the bathroom with a [ __ ] lies
about coke you know it's funny just too
much money no one wants to give it up
that's I say they don't want to share I
say it in my bed it's like your face is
giving it away your jaw's moving all
over you're like I ain't got [ __ ] man
come on wanna share it's not taboo
anymore though I feel like - you know I
mean like everybody does cocaine I don't
think it's it's almost like what I was
in the 90s what I feel like everyone
does cocaine but I feel like a lot of
people do cocaine now in a very casual
sense I think Molly more so like yeah
like I've been on dates with girls that
are like lawyers and they're like yeah I
was doing Molly I was doing a little
coke it's just like yeah yeah well I
always say like you'll hear about the
bad stories of coke you know what I mean
but if the people talked about the good
stories it would be legal like weed yeah
I did coke man I drove so fast down
there
I wrote this hit song yes I did coke
once I did it one time it was I told Dan
and Dan was worried about me I've
literally blown my face off drove out to
Lancaster motel so you you you did
enough that you got numb in the arm yeah
man I'm sure that's gonna get me on the
back end I always say I didn't die
didn't die young but now it's gonna be
like you know Runyon Canyon it was dying
young now was like 45 I know right
it's crazy yeah no one gives a [ __ ]
though if you die in your 40s or just
like I remember my arm went numb and I
was like oh this ain't good
were you drinking and smoking cigarettes
- oh yeah totally so I go over to the
guy on the turret and I go dude you got
it you got a car you eating dairy and
[ __ ] candy i candy while I was doing
unrefined sugar gummi bears
got your problem there's gummy bears
yeah and I went up to the guy who's like
hey dude you gotta call an ambien suzong
oh no he's like you got to ride it out
this [ __ ] there's too much [ __ ] going
on here we can't have cops you know he's
actually a hundred percent right right
right so uh he's I'll just grab that
bottle of Stoli and start pounding it
you'll feel better and I was like
alright cuz I went over he had a giant
walking cause at night I drifted I was
rubbing my arm the whole time like [ __ ]
and I was drinking this vodka and about
a half-hour later came back and I was
like [ __ ] after actually that never did
blow again ever do that yeah but that
was after of like doing it like 10 years
straight yeah I'm out I was like a smart
one I think my arm was numb and that was
pre thank God there was no Google around
like you're having a [ __ ] WebMD yeah
[ __ ] done at the party
what was it did you see that documentary
about that Club in New York where it was
like they were like having it was like a
big electronic thing and the club owner
when kids would OD would just put him in
the basement and then like in the
morning they would just take these dead
kids and like just put him on the street
mouth [ __ ] amazed he's like
apparently like a huge thing like I
don't know what that era was but it was
like 90s rave scene oh wow yeah I mean
the last time I did this is a while
while while ago on my not sober days I
had have I ever talked but I don't think
I've ever talked about this the last
time I did coke it was bad cuz I also I
bought an escort but I couldn't get it
up oh yeah so I just used her to talk
about my problems oh god she had to pay
extra cuz I stayed was in my friend's
trailer that was his in his backyard but
he was outside in the backyard passed
out just like well that he's here so
that's an extra 300 bucks twelve on her
just doomed whoa and then I say anything
I was coming down I just grabbed bottle
of vodka I start chugging Avadh oh and
yeah it was a [ __ ] it was a nightmare
and I pet and you know the thing that my
friend got so terrified because I bought
like that I blacked out yeah and I woke
up and I was fully clothed with coats
and I had a tie on for some reason and I
was holding what time but it was like we
probably asked her to marry him no I was
holding there I was holding a bouquet of
flowers I bought for myself and my
friend and I woke over my friends in the
other bed and he's like looking at me
shaking cuz he didn't do anything he
planned his own funeral yeah if I'm up
early it always reminds me of cocaine
cuz I don't get up early and it was
always those times where you're going to
get booze at like 6:00 a.m. and and and
the real world is happening that's
because you're in a house all night
doing drugs listen to rock ya know 10:00
to 6:00 oh yeah that was like my the one
night I did cocaine was like it was
super fun I was in Vegas I was in like a
suit
we had like we had literally like The
Hangover suite you know like multiple
rooms yeah
and I was like with all these like TV
friends and we're like they're all like
going to bed and I'm like still kind of
loaded and I'm like and I also am not
drinking like I'm like I don't drink but
I'll [ __ ] do like oh hey ball I could
never do coke without that's why I don't
think it no I don't think that's why it
took yeah but it was like 7 a.m. and I
was like I'm gonna go play more
blackjack and I got downstairs I walked
off the elevator lit a cigarette and
then I realized that it was just old
people power walking and I was like I'm
a monster
right now upstairs it's nothing weirder
than being like at a grocery store like
you're getting beer at 6 a.m. and
there's people shopping and you're just
completely [ __ ] fried like any
shopping store to is like when you're
coming off on coke you know what you
want to buy the booze so like flatten
the out so you can sleep it all the way
and I got the grocery store one time at
6:00 a.m. and it was just a bunch of
[ __ ] homeless dudes and me waiting
with our booze and I was like this is
creep because they were doing the same
thing where they're like okay like but
there is it was like long-term alcohol
is right right yeah they need to get my
I need a shake the [ __ ] shakes today
yeah
and they're just and I'm like is this
like kind of a wake up I remember many
kind of a wake-up calls but this is
definitely yeah I mean like there's
nothing like like cuz it's so stupid cuz
you'll like buy the girl and then you
think like oh yeah escort like they took
with the movie in the new bridge that
way you can't get it up anyway never
sitting there you know they got viagra
but when I was about that doing viagra
and I would take Oh cuz then like your
heart's just like yeah that's kind of
blow you know that's like I mean you
know when you're in the 80s man blow is
everywhere I dealers just rolled they
wanted to be part of the scene and the
coke was free so you just and I never
did coke till I was completely drunk so
I can just smooth it out and keep
drinking yeah that was the reason I did
blow blow sober is the grossest thing
ever to me
I can't you could have put pounds of
blow and finally I'd
oh yeah I cannot think of yeah when I'm
with it's funny though now I guess you
know I like I like right now I'm sober
I'm like the idea of just doing a wine
without booze is like disgusting to me
well like if I had one beer I'd be like
okay that's it I'm gonna go to [ __ ]
Spearmint Rhino and talk to the girl
there they wanna like you know they want
to like get you in the room to pay
$1,000 to the dance you got a stripper a
$500 what do you that box of aluminum
foil yeah so is I mean no but that's
that's oh yeah that coming I definitely
if you want to get cocaine and you don't
have a cook up you go to a [ __ ] strip
club oh yeah those are the places to go
but now you you drink still that's right
now I don't do nothing oh really
ninety-two so you don't even have like
you don't even have a beer with dinner
type of stuff you haven't had a beer and
over in 23 years yeah but you never did
program or anything no what happened was
I was a singer in a band and I was
drinking every night and my voice
started [ __ ] go bad when I went to
the doctor and he said look dude you got
like notes like pre nodes which are like
calluses on your vocal cords i watch
this was a that's what brought Harry and
they listened down was like watching
that last night oh I want to see that so
I divers great movie so you know like
Steven Tyler had him recently Adele a
couple years ago you got to get them
lasered off and then you can't talk for
like three weeks and then you have to
retrain singing for like six months and
I was mid touring with a band and you
know that's how we made our living
there's four guys so I go the doctor is
like look you can't drink booze it dries
out your vocal cords and then it
destroys your vocal nobody thinks that
so you're just drinking all night
but the alcohol dries out your vocal
cords that I'm singing and the vocal
cords are pounding each other and
becomes these calluses so you guys if
you quit drinking for a while and don't
talk after gigs they'll probably go away
naturally with like we're colas and tea
and everything
yawn yeah I guess so you never really
although all you did this [ __ ] you never
had you were never addicted I was
definitely a mess you were done I mean
that that was but getting it down or now
well at first I was like well I was so
scared and not being able to sing that
it threw me into a shocker you know and
then I was like whoa I feel way better
and then I could sing great all the
sudden for hours yeah like after like
three four months but yeah I was I would
have been dead
you know what about um so no pills even
after that you know there's no pills
when I was growing up those in LA thing
in the beer it wasn't a bill thing when
I got to LA
everybody's on pills in like 2002 as
eight pills well I think for me it's
like I could never like because
sometimes I like fantasize about I just
smoke weed but then I'm like you don't
want to you want to get high yeah I want
to smoke weed you want to like be able
to take six percocet and show out you
know cuz like that's how I was but I'm
such an addict that like pretty soon I
was smoking like an eight the day and I
wanted to like I was smoking weed
big-time you know quitting like say if
you're quitting because you quit booze
and quit well booze I was just like
always a nightmare yes I was always just
I just don't know how you're able to Tom
is that your dog yeah Tom did you just
get attacked by a rattling Tom that was
tossed wrangling his dog they're telling
a story talking about drugs I thought he
was opening a Bindo and chopping [ __ ] up
yes speaking of yeah she woke up and
shook herself
that's hilarious but shook herself
somebody say coke but I'm just saying
like it for me like weed is like it just
never made me relaxed
that's why did weed maybe Roy I broke
through a wall it was like I would be
paranoid and like scared and then it was
like I just kept doing it yeah and then
one day I was like this is awesome
but it was like I was totally
disconnected I didn't realize like
reality at all I was like by the end I
was like smoking an 8 the day
and I was like planning like a good way
to fake my death this is like ten months
ago like I was like I'll fake my death
and I'll move to Latin America and then
I'll try to become you know you'd faked
your death like anyone would give a [ __ ]
yeah oh my god Andy like faked his death
news would report it if they found you
the fake mustache let me make a disagree
at this American life I'm just trying to
get on Miss America Ella Baker hear me
yeah but so you never really had that
much of a problem of this that's that's
good no I did have I mean I'm what I
mean like you didn't have to go through
the shakes well the thing was it was
crazy hard to quit but something meant
more to me you know I mean playing music
yeah and I and I kinda had this work I
have the same work ethic as comedy I was
like well I got these three guys man I
can't [ __ ] them you know we work
together to do something and we made a
record and now I can't go out and tour
it that would be a nightmare yeah yeah
and I loved music I mean I lost a great
woman to music why would I why would I
[ __ ] let the booze but I was a I
would go on binges seven day five days
that kind of [ __ ] like I was way into
like Hunter s Thompson right
I love Drugstore Cowboy I love that
[ __ ] dark world of like taking the
drugs and seeing where it takes you like
jamming all night on mushrooms in a
studio yeah that's like I when I have an
urge to get [ __ ] up I don't have an
urge to like do a bunch of coke and go
to a party now I want to go to the
desert and see a Fox's head in the sky
[ __ ] I'm in I want to shoot like guns at
the moon I want to now leave my
apartment for three days you write a
great screenplay I'll get through all
house
there's nothing like exotic about my
fantasies either I got what's the
farthest I can get away without anyone
knowing yeah man I like I like that
weird [ __ ] dark world yeah when I go
I want to do that that's a that's always
what brought me to drugs yeah that's why
I left mushrooms you just [ __ ] you're
with do a couple dudes you're out doing
shrooms and you're like this is [ __ ]
quit your mind it's so amazing where
your mind can go on psychedelics I stand
up versus music now five and a half
years stand up 25 years music or was it
a weird transition well the everything
was pretty normal except for the writing
part are you getting laughs in between
songs that were towards the end of my
music career I was doing an acoustic
tour with wallflowers and I would tell
stories like vh1 storytellers huh and I
could see that it was killing you know
my soul and in my mind I was like you
know I saw louis c.k around the era of
awesome possum that era jokes though and
I was like who is this guy and it really
set me into like I want to do Stu I
wanted to do stand-up my entire life my
entire life but when I was a kid there
was no kids doing stand-up it was like
adults you know it was like Richard
Pryor Cheech and Chong Carlin and I had
all those records but it wasn't kids
going yeah we do it too so I started
playing music in than 25 years went by
the music's the cooler choice yeah the
only thing I just wish that I get good
at it I wish I could jam like I wish I
could sit down at a piano or like a
guitar and just cuz I like I can sit
down and write but I would like you
can't just sit there in your house and
be like you know like the other day I
was at the grocery store just
did I tell you I'm when I was in high
school for like this is like a man they
had a recording of this my life would be
ruined like that it was I tried singing
as like Zack de la Rocha is the machine
man and like like rap Rocking yeah like
while my friends played and like sorta
like but I was like talking about my
parents not understanding us and show oh
my god we and then I called him was you
want to do that again there right now
we're gonna do do it with somebody
because I was like screaming and there
it was bad I remember when I started
comedy it was really sad I was in that
living room like like I thought it was
like music where you just rehearsed just
running my set and I thought I'm going
to go pro or whatever and I was like
this is [ __ ] I'm never doing this ever
dude I used to I used to before mics I
would come three hours earlier just to
get my mic hold the hell no figure out
how to holding the mic woah yeah that's
crazy I skipped all that because I had
yet with music so the only real thing
that was was was really finding me you
know not trying to be another guy you
know like with music you have all these
influences but when you first start with
music you're playing covers so you're
wearing music by playing other people's
music you can't learn comedy by just
going when I started I did Eddie Murphy
yeah give us AIDS crazy man he was a lad
he bought that and had it taken our
distribution oh he did oh you can't buy
raw like on DVD really yeah that was
probably the smartest thing that he had
let's forget about some of the things I
said yeah especially because like a
couple months later he got caught with a
transsexual prostitute yeah so whatever
happened the guy who played powder
unrelated powder what's going on during
an energy
he was molested when he was 12 pi light
[Laughter]
a waterfall took advantage of me
remember when I don't know any of this
remember when you and war this is like
one of the saddest open my and bhavam
Andy's hilarious in Mike Warren it was
really funny you know I think I have
like two years on more on Dan not yes
we're both pretty much at the blue yeah
I was in I started in Seattle I did like
nine months community for my college I
went to DC for two years and then I went
to New York gotcha
Andy was but I remember one like my I
was like an open mic and my chorus came
up and Mike Mike said like Mike did a
story about how he's molested is a bit
and then Andy got on Africa's mic you
weren't molested I was molested what are
we but even you were right but even
though you were right it was like the
saddest victory of all time
that I am NOT proud of that I am
molested as a child in a body cast Mike
was like at a deep fryer and gay man
rubbed up
wait a minute your stories in stage like
cocky like yeah that's how you get
molested
[Applause]
[ __ ] you warns Jesus Andy that guy he is
[ __ ] be still working John the guy
Sean Patrick Flanery is the guy's name
wait to get the writer no I mean maybe
powder powder yeah oh I think the guy
who molested he's still working like I
consider it like I was an open mic oh we
got a rap Bob unfortunately I wish we
could do this longer but we can thanks
for having thank you for doing it man I
want to plug it come out next week oh
yeah this week's podcast on the same
network all things comedy it's called
let to be talk and I'm gonna have Jerry
from Devo on this week's Eve as one of
my all-time favorites I'm just got more
excited about your podcast than he's
ever been
Devo is absolutely top three bands for
me ever shirt yeah I mean if you think
about those guys through in Akron Ohio
1972 three or four and start playing
that music yeah exactly
Nashville because that's where they get
to run into
Jack Jack White and hate each other they
hate each other like Jack White took his
kids out of the same school that the
Black Keys what are you doing today is
Sherry's birthday by the way it is
yeah no wonder he couldn't do today I go
yeah that's you know the guy from DeVos
birth I got his computer do you know
because we tell me you have do you have
the computer honor now
Zenvo no because I follow CBGB on
Facebook and they posted picture home of
Jerry this morning saying happy I
thought you just knew that CBGB the the
now John Varvatos or you know what's
amazing about Jerry was he was the guy
that came up with the outfits the hats
and he all and all the outfits the
yellow suits that hats and he also
directed all those killer videos and
they had films they never had an opening
band you'd go see him and they had films
that were [ __ ] wacky were they like
art students or yeah yeah yeah yeah and
they would he went to Kent State
shooting what he was there he stood next
to one of the guys that got shot he was
a hippie at Kent State in the next day
he said [ __ ] hippies and started Devo
you know he had the opposite reaction
that everyone else yeah crazy you know
these cops are right let's spread some
other work you know why are you doing
the Nene broad stuff you done going out
with I just got off the Marin tour it
ended on Sunday which is a bummer for me
I'll be Denver Comedy Works August Andy
what do you got coming up thanks Andy I
got some stuff I'm gonna be in I'll be
at the city winery in Napa yeah Thursday
the 27th yeah wait it's a month and I'll
be this Thomas comes in on Thursday yes
okay so a Thursday night I'll be a Doc's
lab so comes to see that and then Friday
I'll be in Friday else to be in saver
but Saturday I'll be in Santa Cruz and
Sunday I'll be in Sonoma and then Monday
I'll be in Humboldt northern Cali I want
to go to Bohemian Grove yeah I want to
figure out what's going on up there
you've been through the redwoods no oh
there's a small town there forget the
arbor Garberville yeah no it's great
that's like so cool when they log house
there she'll see it attend the main
strip when I was I was like going down
to do the San Francisco comedy
competition with Rory Scovel yeah and we
were doing mushrooms in the redwoods and
we like we're walking through the
redwoods and we just found two ounces of
weed on the ground yeah yeah we hit it
and then the next day came back and got
it cuz we were like they're gonna shoot
us for their two ounces super paranoid I
think we ran home 15th on Facebook yeah
Rory you can just check out all he
really needs it guys so I can't get him
on this show he was on two three months
ago yeah
now we can get all we can get all people
I knew what great thank you very much it
was fun that's a fun that was really
that was a great room it was really fun
come back and do it again I would love
to do it again and I had a kind of an
awkward interaction like cuz I was about
to go to the store one girl who was
there and I said she like 70 she goes I
asked her out like two months ago and
she's like did you do you know my friend
and this is another girl I asked yeah
yeah and I was like [ __ ]
well now I'm doubly not getting laid oh
well anyway you can read all about that
on my on my life journal alright Debu
winter but
thanks for listening to the my dumb
friends podcast here's where you can see
our hosts performing live this week as
Dan mentioned he's making a trip up to
Northern California where he will be
performing on Thursday July 30th at
Doc's lab in San Francisco at around 8
p.m. on Saturday August 1st he will be
performing at the crepe place in Santa
Cruz California on Sunday the 2nd of
August he will be performing at Murphy's
Irish pub in Sonoma California and on
Monday August 3rd he'll be performing at
hum brews in Arcata California up near
Humboldt and then he's back in the Los
Angeles metropolitan area for more
information about locations and times go
to Dan st. Germain dotnet our good
friend Sean Donnelly is performing in
and around New York City all this week
at everywhere from the village
underground to the world-famous Comedy
Cellar
for more specifics on locations and
times go to Sean Donnelly comedy comm
we'd love to hear from you please write
us a letter to my dumb friends podcast
at gmail.com we'd love if more of you
could drop us a few bucks to keep our
podcast going you can do a safe and
secure PayPal donation by finding the
link at our tumblr page which is at my
dumb friends podcast tumblr.com rate and
review us on iTunes and stitcher
give us all those stars and write a
sentence or two it would really help us
out
you